a mass genocide of these Native
Americans by the very same pilgrims
that's an undeniable fact of American
history that we cannot ignore to ignore
that and pretend that it did not happen
I think would be uh inherently racist
but that doesn't change what
Thanksgiving is first what a lot of
people do is they try and take actions
afterward acts of evil committed
afterward to discredit the idea of
Thanksgiving if we do that that sets a
precedent we could do it for any holiday
we do it for Christmas we could do it
for Veterans Day we could do it for
Memorial Day we could do it for Labor
Day but we choose what we celebrate and
we choose to celebrate a very specific
instance in 16
where the pilgrims peacefully broke
bread and feasted with Native Americans
and that peace lasted for 50 years
Thanksgiving is a good holiday